وافادت الاداره العسكريه في زابوروجيا
جنوب شرقيه اوكرانيا بمقتل امراه قتلت
واصابه 19 في قصر روسي استهدف احد فنادق
المدينه وقالت الداخليه الاوكرانيه ان
الصاروخ المستخدم هو روسي من نوع اسكندر
من جهته وصف منسق الامم المتحده للشعود
الانسانيه في اوكرانيا دنس براون الهجوم
بغير المقبول مشيرا الى ان موظفي الامم
المتحده وممثل المنظمات الانسانيه الاخرى
استخدموا الفندق خلال عملياتهم الاغاثيه
في هذه المنطقه
المتابعه معنا الامن العده مراسل الجزيره
عامر لافي ومن موسكو مراسله الجزيره رانيا
الدريدي للوقوف طبعا على اخر التطورات
الميدانيه ارحب بكما وابدا معك
بالتطورات المدنيه في الجانب الاوكرانيه
نعم ازدهار يعني ربما ابرز ما جرى اليوم
هو محاوله القوات الروسيه استهداف العاصمه
بصواريخ من نوع تنجال ومن نوع خاء ايضا
قياده العسكريه في كييف تحدثت عن تمكنها
من اسقاط كل الصواريخ التي استهدفت
العاصمه وحطام ثلاث صواريخ عثر عليها حتى
الان الاول سقط في بهو لمستشفى للاطفال لم
ينتج عنه اي اضرار اخر صاروخ اخر سقط على
سقف احد المنازل وخلف اضرارا بسيطه اما
الصاروخ الثالث ف عثر عليه في منطقه
مفتوحه خارج العاصمه كييف اذا هذه
الصواريخ في كييف لكن هناك مناطق اخرى
ازدهار في اوكرانيا استهدفتها هذه
الصواريخ وتحديدا في منطقه ذكر باطيه هذه
المنطقه التي تقع في غرب اوكرانيا سقطت
عده صواريخ علمنا قبل قليل من الاداره
العسكريه في تلك المنطقه بان طفلا في
الثامنه من عمره قتل جراء استهداف منزل
هذا الطفل وبالاضافه الى اصابه عدد من
الاشخاص في هذا الاستهداف الذي تقول
الاداره هناك بان الاستهداف كان للبنيه
التحتيه ولمناطق سكنيه في تلك المنطقه
الاستهداف طبعا للاحياء السكنيه مستمر هنا
في الجنوب كما ذكرتم قبل قليل في زبوجيا
التي استهدف لليوم الثاني على التواليت
امراه وبعد استهداف هذا الفندق الذي
بالمناسبه قياده القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه تحدثت عن ان هذا الفندق كان
ينظم فيه فعاليه للاطفال قبل سقوط
الصواريخ وانها انتهت قبل تقريبا ساعه من
سقوط هذا الصاروخ وربما لو كان قد سقط قبل
ذلك لكانت يعني حجم الكارثه كان سيكون
كبير كما قال القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
ايضا استهداف لمدينه خرسوان في اكثر من
منطقه اليوم منذ الصباح ادت الى مقتل رجل
في الستين من عمره واصابه خمسه احدهم هو
من الرجال الاطفاء او الدفاع المدني في
مدينه خرسون اذا هذه الاستهدافات بشكل عام
والمستمر كما قلنا لكن تبقى الجبهات
محتدمه من الشمال حتى الجنوب في شرق
البلاد ونخص بالذكر طبعا الجبهه الاسخى
حاليا وهي جبهه كوبيانس يقول الاوكرانيين
نعم بان هناك محاوله للتقدم وتقدم ويصفوه
بالطفيف في هذا المحور كومباسكي شرق هركيف
لكن يقول الاوكرانيين والجيش الاوكراني
بان هناك خسائر كبيره يتكبدها الجانب
الروسي جراء هذه المحاولات المتحدث باسم
العمليات في المنطقه الشرقيه
قال وصف ما يجري هناك بانه محاوله لتقليد
السيناريو التي كانت تتبعه فاجنر في مخمود
وقال بانهم يعيدون كره مفرمه اللحم هذا هو
الوصف الذي كان يستخدمه عند الحديث عن
محمود لماذا لانهم يلقون باعداد كبيره من
المشاه يتم قتلهم في ساحه المعركه مع
احراز تقدم بسيط جدا وهو ما يجري في
كوبيانس حاليا نعم ننتقل الى رانيا دريدي
والروايه الروسيه متعلقه بالتطورات
الميدانيه رانيا
يعني فيما يتعلق بالتطورات الميدانيه على
الاقل وفقا لما نسمعه يوميا من قبل وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه لاسيما الناطق باسمها فان
الهجوم العسكري المضاد وهو ما اكدت عليهم
فشل حسب تعبيرهم القوات الاوكرانيه لم
تحقق اي نجاحات لم تحقق اي تقدم ولا على
اي محور من المحاور الحديثه هنا عن محاور
رئيسيه حاليا وهي محور زباروجيا محور محور
لوغانسك كوبيان
وما الى ذلك كل هذه المحاور لم يتم تحقيق
اي تقدم بها بل وعلى العكس تتحدث وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه عن ان خسائر القوات
الاوكرانيه فادحه في هذه المراحل الحديث
يدور عن مقتل نحو 500 عسكري اوكراني بشبه
يوميا ازدهار على سبيل المثال امس بلغت
خسائر القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه 700 شخص
خلال 24
ساعه فقط وفقا لبعض المصادر العسكريه يعني
هناك عمليات عسكريه محتدمه لا سيما في
محور زباروجيا وكوبانس في محور كوبيانس
وزاره الدفاع اكدت على انها على ان القوات
الروسيه قامت بالسيطره على مواقع يعني
عسكريه استراتيجيه تابعه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه في هذا المحور ومصادر عسكريه
اخرى تحدثت عن هجوم عسكري روسي يعني ضربات
صاروخيه روسيه استهدفت مواقع لتمركز
المرتزقه الاجانب في مقاطعه اليوم
وبالاشاره لان يعني العشرات منهم لقوا
حتفهم وان اكثر من 70 اخرين اصيبوا بجروح
هذا فيما يتعلق بشكل مقتضب ازدهار بتطورات
الاوضاع على الجبهات ولكن لو تحدثنا عن
تطورات الوضع يعني ميزانيا هنا في العاصمه
موسكو اود الاشاره الى ان الهجمات
بالمسيرات الاوكرانيه على ما يبدو هي
مستمره اليوم كانت هناك
اخرى عمليه هجوم اخرى يعني تم يعني تم
تنفيذها باستخدام مسيره في منطقه كراميش
التي تقع شمال غرب العاصمه موسكو هذه
المسيره كانت تريد استهداف مواقع وبنى
تحتيه مدنيه في العاصمه بحسب تصريحات عمده
العاصمه ولكن تم اسقاطها دون ان تلحق اي
اضرار ماديه او ان تقوم يعني يعني الحاق
واصابات في صفوف المدنيين هذه الهجمات
وفقا لما نشاهده في الاونه الاخيره ازدهار
قد ازدادت صارت يعني اصبحت هذه الهجمات
متكرره اصبحت شيئا ما روتينيه فخلال
الايام الاربعه الماضيه تم مهاجمه العاصمه
موسكو اربع مرات ولكن مع ذلك الجانب
الروسي يتحدث عن ان مثل هذه الخطوات يقوم
الجانب الاوكراني باتخاذها وذلك على خلفيه
فشله في الهجوم المضاد ومحاولاته لاظهار
انه يحقق ولو اي نجاحات
ولا سيما لرعاته الغربيين بحسب وزاره
الدفاع شكرا جزيلا لك من موسكو مراسله
الجزيره رانيا دريديسا مراسله الجزيره
عامر لافي شكرا جزيلا لكم